it's an opportunity to bring rebecca
myers and david ornstein uh
back in to take us through uh the
newspapers and of course
nick still with me we have had the metro
in
um so far and their headline um if we
can bring that up
yeah that's just coming up but it's a
picture i believe
and uh the actual headline is lions did
us proud and david that um although the
fans were terribly disappointed
that was the sentiment that came across
tonight for the ones that we spoke to
that they were incredibly proud of what
england had achieved
thus far and it was so close but still
proud of what they'd done
and rightly so how long has it been
since england
were even in contention real contention
for
a major tournament the 2018 world cup
england got to the semi-finals but they
were outplayed by croatia before they
even got to the
final hurdle on this occasion england
were rightly in contention
and were a bit of luck away from getting
their hands
on that trophy we've also seen a lot of
young players come of age during this
tournament
and the person you saw there in that
image picayo saka for example
we saw a great performance by jayden
sancho in the ukraine quarterfinal
in rome there's been mason mount another
young player declan rice calvin phillips
great story
with those two even jordan pickford in
goal has proved a lot of
doubt is wrong and it's not just the
quality of those players it's what they
bring as people too
we've seen the likes of marcus rashford
and his work in the last year or so
with child food poverty um raheem
sterling the boy from brent and
and all the adversity he's faced in his
life and his career
stepping up to the plate and he was
probably england's best player
in this tournament jack relish it wasn't
quite quite the tournament that maybe
many hoped for him but
this is a team that is packed with
talent packed with potential phil foden
who was of course injured for the final
made an impact in the first couple of
games as well also in the semi-final as
a substitute so
i think there's a real good feeling in
this country that the the team can go on
to greater things
there will be scrutiny and i've spoken
to people in the game tonight who are
astonished that
in a match of such magnitude with so
much talent at his disposal gary
southgate didn't get england playing a
more attractive brand of football
tonight
and uh that is going to be a theme of
conversation
also of course those late substitutions
and
the penalty kicks bringing on two
players who were cold who were
according to the television coverage
alan shearer was saying you don't bring
them on at that stage they're not in the
game mentally physically
and then to take two penalties it's no
coincidence perhaps that they missed
and then a 19 year old taking the
biggest penalty in england's
history really we've never had a penalty
in a world cup fight
in a major tournament final before and
so i think these are all mitigating
factors which mean
that sentiment will be quite positive
there will be a feel-good factor around
the country
these players will be recognized and
backed i think
i don't think that i hope there's not
going to be the same sort of
recriminations
that we've seen in previous major
tournaments italia 90 the 98 world cup
uh you know previous euros
euro 96 of course gareth southgate
himself we don't want to see
players held up as villains we don't
want to see them
castigated for their their misses or or
some mistakes
i think this is a different time now
with different characters
with diverse characters players and a
great
opportunity to go on to do good things
perhaps this is just the start of a
really
good period for english football and
let's hope that there's not that sort of
negativity that we've seen in the past
okay uh david thanks very much for that
we're going to be back to you in a
second just want to
bring you a little bit of breaking news
and this is from
boris johnson this is what he has
tweeted the prime minister said
that was a heartbreaking result to end
euro 2020
but gareth southgate and his england
squad played
like heroes they have done the nation
proud and deserve
great credit flag of england so that's
uh
the latest tweet from boris johnson just
to bring you some news on that that
security issue that we were talking
about
um at the game tonight metropolitan
police
have said that they've made 45 arrests
while policing today's euro 2020 final
uh a number of officers remain on duty
helping fans leaving
wembley or central london we are there
to look out
for your safety uh rebecca that's
something that we'd
spoken about previously that the game
was somewhat marred by
those fans charging and trying to enter
the stadium without
tickets it really was and it was quite
obviously quite hard to see that in the
build-up especially in light of how
positive the atmosphere had felt in
you know previous matches and how we
hoped it would be interesting to see
that there's already
45 arrests i wonder if there might be
more i will also be really interested to
see actually
how the sort of the fa how gareth
respond to what happened tonight whether
there will be statements issued
um you know i think and i loved seeing
that front page there i think that
really symbolizes the kind of leadership
um that gareth has had this tournament
and that is the kind of
you know leadership that we you know we
would hope that our fans would be seeing
and trying to emulate or trying to
um you know show in in their own
behavior so i wonder if there may be
some messaging
coming from um the fa coming from
england i did see a tweet actually from
england which sort of
um showed quite a calm gareth
celebrating the goal saying sort of be
more gareth and i wonder if there's
going to be
um some more work around that because it
was hugely disappointing to see what we
did tonight and
and you know there has to be action to
show that it isn't acceptable
yeah rebecca and david uh thank you for
the moment we're still
waiting for the papers to come in and we
shall bring those as soon as they arrive
but in the meantime
we can speak to martin lipton chief
sports reporter at the sun
uh martin um can you tell us what your
headline will be
uh i can't actually but i'm sure it will
be one that uh
uh catches the mood of the of the
country which is a
huge pride uh and disappointment mixed
together
but more the former than the latter um
that was an incredible run
to the final over the 120 minutes
they were beaten by the better team it
went to penalties italy were better
over the match for me always looked
particularly in the second half the more
likely
but that shouldn't take away from the
run that england have had the fact that
they've had you know
unbeaten in the tournament because
penalty shootouts are you know an add-on
as it were a way of settling a tie
but the game was drawn uh and they've
had a superb series of
of displays under the manager and have
grown as
a team over the last month and um
you say that that you believe italy was
the better side was that
consistently throughout the game because
we had that very very early goal in what
was it one minute 56 57 seconds
um before we'd even blinked yeah almost
too early
a bit reminiscent of the third minute
goal that shiva scored against germany
in 96 in the semi-final
often you you know you the game hasn't
settled they can start all over again
without the impact ever
of the goal england shaded the first
half italy dominated the second half
extra time was fairly even could have
gone either way but over the whole 120
italy were better
you're allowed to be better than the
other team you're allowed to acknowledge
the other team are better than you
it doesn't mean that england couldn't
have won they were a couple of kicks
away from winning it and sometimes the
better team doesn't win on this occasion
the better team did win did your heart
sink when you
absolutely realized that it was going to
penalties or were you still optimistic
at that point
i was quite phlegmatic about it um i
felt that uh i know that gala southgate
thought that um
jordan pickford being in goal might make
the difference because he's been a lucky
omen in two previous
penalty shootouts he's made two saves to
save from georgina was absolutely
outstanding
unfortunately sacker missed and
therefore you know england lose
it's not a lottery it's a test of skill
and nerve
but it's also the finest and the most
fragile of tests and even great players
like franco barrazi
have missed penalties in world cup
finals great players like dinners
indiana have missed penalties
when it matches some of the greatest
players in the history of game of the
game of missed penalties in shootouts
unfortunately someone has to lose on
this occasion england lost
but semi-final in the world cup
semi-final in the nations league final
in the euros
sometimes you need to learn how to lose
before you learn how to win and look at
germany
they were semi-finalists semi-finalists
losing finalists
they won 2014 world cup the team grew
together
through adversity through the pain
england
now look to do the same thing and
they've only got 16 17 months to wait
before the world cup takes place in
qatar
assuming they qualify of course would
you criticize gareth southgate for
the choices he made in the players that
actually took the penalties or or
are you saying that's just the way the
cookie crumbles it was the plan for
those players to take the penalties
that clearly he doesn't send them on
unless it's to take penalties
because you wouldn't have made that
change otherwise it had been pre-planned
you know he'd actually gone through it
and thought it through and discussed it
before the game with the players they
knew
if it came to it but there was a chance
they would take them
that is it you know and if rashford hits
the inside of the post and goes in
rather than the outside and goes out no
one's criticizing
it's easy to second guess to be the
coach from the touchline to be the you
know
looking at the video booth and then
calling it the manager made the
decisions
sometimes it doesn't work italy missed
two penalties they weren't precise
themselves you know it's
is gossamer thin
yeah martin lipton thank you very much
for your uh insightful analysis thank
you so much for speaking to us this
evening
nick sitting here listening to all of
that um
yeah we all do try and be sort of
critics sitting at the sideline but from
what
martin was saying there it is about
skill
many people saying that the penalties
it's luck it's bad luck
but masterpiece skills it's not bad like
cause it's about skill
it's not a bad luck and it's it was a
calculated
gamble that gareth southgate took and
there were plenty of us i'm sure
watching thinking i hope this works
it is a danger you bring on players who
are cold to use
david ornstein's world word um
it's a gamble you you martin's right
that was the plan you bring him on
because you think they're your best
penalty takers
southgate has said they've been taking
them really well in in training
fine but it is a gamble it didn't pay
off but
southgate has done plenty over the
last three four years to
get over that and to not have the
treatment at the hands of
the media that past managers have done
he's achieved far more than that
england have been in the fight let's not
forget 55 years okay
penalty shootout might not have been
perfect but we look back in this
tournament
with some pride and with some hope for
qatar next year as martin says assuming
we qualified we should
yeah yeah we got to the final we got to
the final that's the positive that we we
must look at uh
rebecca just returning to the metro and
that photo which
i have to say breaks my heart of gareth
southgate
hugging uh sekka because you just think
he's so
young and to be under so much pressure
and now
sadly this is what he will be known for
you can only imagine how he feels
tonight
yeah it's impossible to put yourself in
those shoes but i do think in a way
you know we've already seen from some of
those reactions coming from your
correspondence kind of out in the fan
zones
there's already a huge amount of love
for him a huge amount of empathy with
what he must be going through
i don't think anyone is going to sort of
think this is going to define his career
by any stretch
we've seen throughout the tournament he
has just been phenomenal
he's played under really high pressure
moments in games you know obviously this
is
a high pressure moment where it didn't
quite work out for him but he's shown
that he can handle that pressure
on the pitch and be you know a game
changer in many many ways so i don't
think this will define his career i
don't think this is gonna
you know i certainly hope as nick said
that we won't see
um any kind of sort of you know
sort of negativity directed towards him
and that there will just be empathy
understanding for what he's gone through
and like that metro front page pride you
know they've done something incredible
regardless of what happened tonight
we will always remember this sort of run
we will always remember tonight
um and they have done something historic
and i think the country is genuinely
truly proud of them
and david there's no better person to
support him
through this than gary southgate himself
yeah he'll be able to uh empathize as
rebecca quite rightly points out he's
been there himself
it was the most infamous moment really
in english football history in 1996 and
look at how southgate has
rebuilt his career especially on the
management side but he was also
a successful player as well he has been
as a person heroic as a manager for
england gareth southgate
he was actually an accidental
appointment in a way i think it was back
in 2016 when he
uh was not too sure about taking the job
on a permanent basis after sam
allardyce's departure
he ended up doing so and he's done very
well indeed
there was the 2014 world cup just before
in
in brazil roy hodgson didn't get out of
the group stage
uh 2016 the shame of iceland and then
later that year
um southgate came in after sam halliday
aladdin short reign and it's been an
upward
trajectory ever since um the obviously
the last major tournament the world cup
in russia
and now gareth southgate has bonded a
magnificent group of players and saka
very much part of that there were some
people who were thinking that saka
wasn't going to make this squad at all
in fact he came into the side for the
third group game he retained his uh
his place for the last 16 match um
and then they changed for the
quarter-finals came back in for the
semi-finals and featured
in no small part tonight as well so um i
think sakura is really strong mentally
i've covered a lot of his time at
arsenal obviously only a very short time
because he's such a young man at 19
years old
um but he's got a really thick skin
already he's a
generational talent quite magnificent
player and if you speak to anybody who
saw him coming through at the arsenal
academy has worked with him has played
with him
they speak about how he's got an old
head on young shoulders he's got a
maturity beyond his years
he's a straight a student he's got a
magnificent physical
technical tactical understanding is
decision making is superb
and as i tweeted out a short time ago i
don't think one penalty save changes a
single thing about bakay osaka now we
mustn't get away from the fact that
there will be some rebuilding that needs
to take place in his confidence in his
belief but he'll have a break now he'll
go off to pre-season
uh with arsenal he'll have mikhail
arteta his manager there to put an arm
around him
and to help him get back on the path but
even though we saw him very emotional at
the end
quite soon he appeared to have
recomposed himself and that's the
bakayosaka
and many of us have come to know i think
he's going to be an absolute superstar
player
his bar is so so high he's got
lots of development to do and uh yeah
he's got a great person alongside him at
the national team in gareth southgate
but i think he
his family a strong support a club
behind him he will be just fine
okay it's good to hear that uh appraisal
there that he's so
resilient david and rebecca do stay with
us we're going to take a break this is
the press
preview now and the first of the front
pages are just starting to come through
this is the daily mirror heartbreak is
how it describes england's defeat
to italy coming up we'll be discussing
that
and the rest of the papers as they run
do stay with us
[Music]
you